hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Skyrim okay we are looking at
Lydia we're also here to find some guy
named elderberry sans burg the third
Davenport and McClaren Smith I don't
know this is the way we came Lydia Oh
Lydia Lydia let you Thank You Lydia yeah
it what that oh yeah yeah I'm an idiot
there's elv down here stinking elves
no-good dirty elves who needs him anyway
oh damn dirty elves the hell can I go in
I just jump down thank you thank you
very much are the elves here to kill
this guy or something and if so how did
they know about him that's when I'm
wondering someone's told it was that
lady the lady in the end
bring it on anyone even down here
he's not very well-hidden if there are
elves just like right here ready to
murder him hello for you I'm gonna eat
well tonight what yeah well but you're
not
the hell was that about if I was in a
chef's hat that oh haha he wanted to eat
me I guess I do look pretty good being
an Argonian and all but no I don't think
so
now excuse me Lydia pop me hello
as burn that's the guy no yes you are
what you're talking about
yes you do come on so you finally found
her huh huh and she led you to me
and Here I am caught like a rat in a
trap yeah um yeah that one there was
something else you told me d-dan arm
there then feel really alive
you'd better come in there and tell me
how you're following me and what you
this is the guy that did the voice
before that the intro for the things
you'll just take a moment I recognize
him
you know songs it dawns in fire that one
who's laughing what what's going on okay
lovely have your stuff can I have your
stuff
can I so taking it one no not again oh
oh oh this flow is turning the world oh
my god oh
the dragon from the door aha no one can
escape his huh uh-huh I try to tell them
okay literal end of the world Lydia did
you kill someone Lydia only a dragon
birds are stomping it seems that the
grass may have grown tired of us they've
left us 12 feet I'm drugged lazy of what
you are yeah I'm a freakin Argonian on
half dragon hope the gods have no noble
school yes okay
but first I'm gonna take all your [ __ ]
please yes please mine Oh get out of
here ah my food damn it alright there's
nothing there any useful stuff huh you
were just gonna leave all this stuff
behind that douche you are and I guess
what let's be awful let's be off ooh
there's potion down there I think we
should have alteration I'll tell wine
destruction butterfly wing Skeever tail
that's it alright
I swear hear voices
no no again I hear this lady this death
lady she's somewhere oh yeah hey Lydia
you got right in the way Lydia I'm sorry
young Achtung
Oh done like a boss TJ okay tell what
I'm doing in a murdering oh I don't know
okay now we're going back out to
Delphine don't I carry her on her way so
that this guy knows something about
someone about how to stop the Dragons I
need to stop him III like to kill him
for loot I mean they don't seem all that
world-ending okay gold coin coin purse
chess committee chest Wow now that's
what's supposed to be in a chest I got
this damn it got it I'm so torch gasps
guru Arjan tea since all of you were
screaming at me to get a friggin torch
boom I'm the best how's it Drive it
trevin's bow what do I care about
dragons bow it's not like a quest item
well I don't care because I'm not doing
side quests I'm doing the main quest
main quest only ah hide breakers of
smithing hammer leather strips engine ah
got a crick in my back
ah man I was doing some extreme game
playing and I just worked it as I was
doing a celebration
victory dance move I don't know I don't
know I was lifting bags of mulch
actually today haulin cubes
Harlen cubes yeah hey watch the office
no yes no okay it was a stupid trap it
failed man long way back I can't just
like yeah that was just looping up and
up and up and up and up the same
direction a lot of waste of my life
anyone in here I need to kill warned
out of my way old ass burn don't make me
do ah ah this is where I fell down got
you I got you I got the gloves are the
pugilist that's where I came in and this
is where I come out finally oh man
how's this those are all sorts of back
and forth that I didn't need to go
through oh I'm in such pain but I'm
toughing it out for you guys Eric and
faster Oh back to River wood I mean like
I don't know if like the whole game is
like based on a river wood but
everything I've been doing so far is
just in Riverwood
oh isn't that fantastic for Nord screwed
them screw Nords Nords are [ __ ] Puffy's
argonians where it's at it's nighttime
Falls oh yeah someone said I could wait
I can't believe I forgot about waiting
just wait laya keep me warm while I
stand here like a statue for nine hours
Lydia what are you doing Lee are you
doing anything no you did nothing you've
kept s burned warm wait where is that
burn maybe I didn't need to wait at all
whoa oh okay I suppose I could have just
gone in the end because that's where
Delphine was and that's where I needed
to go down okay shut up stop stop
talking to her I need to talk to her the
blades of all now are put together it's
good to see you husband it's been too
long old friend too long
well then you made it safe and sound
uh-huh come on go get a room or two yeah
sure yeah sure
this way organ our organ are comply I'll
hurry up lady
God everyone moves so slow in this world
I don't know what it is but people just
want to get on my nerves oh I can
disenchant that thingamabob er yeah yeah
disenchant gloved up pugilist yep blows
up here's your last go pull on fist
weapons but no no that's silly
let's go burn oh come on screw as burn
as burn you better talk quick I mean I
assume what are you showing me give me
just
yeah here is it huh okay doing the
Macarena you see right here Sky Haven
temple constructed around one of the
main our cavalry military camps in the
reach their conquest of Skyrim right no
why would I
this is what is this what is this old
man taking this I'm taking this - want
to sit down install the forgetfulness of
sentries uh-huh a wise and four-sided
policy in the event despite the
far-reaching fame Cochran's role
to talk oh yeah the wonders of the
ancient world its location was lost that
seems likely what are you getting you
mean you don't mean to say you haven't
heard or doing oh let's pretend we
haven't I've only been the drain board
for like five days so yeah all doings
wall well how the ancient blades
recorded all the new part history part
prophecy uh-huh location has been lost
for centuries I not you man just for the
best around me secret I was unable to
save a few scraps finally I have an
objective screw you guys I'm going for
it yes I'm going for you yeah whoa what
done oh I'm going for it
you guys screw you I'm going for it I
have an objective and I'm going for it
whoa oh oh why is it still there why is
the mini the little map oh well lol okay
there we go
much better now all the wins wall easy
that roar extend roar extend that's
where that's where the dude that's where
the dude guys from oh but that's gonna
be a walk can I just I don't think I can
get I can take I can take yeah I can
take the occur the the the carriage to
mark hath mark hath and then go down
there from there I should that should be
fun I don't see why that would be a
problem why it's run woof I can never
read those ooh
or I could buy a horse I get my horse
actually what I need to do is I need to
sell some of my crap
I've got I've got like giant piles a
crap piling up I just need to get rid of
it
most shops are open from about 8 a.m. to
8 p.m. if a shop is closed wait until
morning or pick the lock and break in ha
ha ha aus burn you are you following me
don't feed what the hell they are
following me okay got some good pieces
uh-huh unclaimed okay that's great why
my shins and take all of those this
extra pair of that I have take one of
these actually just keep the orcish bow
and those are worth something
miscellaneous keep most of these whoops
ah [ __ ] up fat [ __ ] it I don't need it
let it up Lydia give me your give me
your [ __ ] I know you have it let COFF it
up no don't leave me don't leave me
Lydia no following okay Dani don't leave
me don't leave me what do you want me to
carry I thought you were gonna be gone
forever okay no these are what I'm
looking for
these are whatever they want from you
and Delvin mace one hunting boat and the
blade sword I hope this wasn't just like
a special sword for you guys I'm gonna
you know take it are you using this
orcish great sword or not make up your
mind don't leave me
could never I can ever see my father
looking no I have not met your father
damage don't care who your father is
wow you got a lot of gold oh yeah
done done and done
now the rest of the crop to the random
crap merchant come on Bella thor bella
thorne huh everything's for sale
everything's for sale okay take that
don't ask why there's blood all over
those I'll take these party crap that
boots once again don't ask about the
blood you don't want to know strength no
ah
you [ __ ] all right that's you and
that that's enough crab selling for now
I mean I've got those dragon bones that
I could probably sell but then again I
don't really need the gold get back to
the stables I think I'm gonna buy myself
a pony ha
and Lydia will just have to run to keep
up this guy might like you need cannot
buy a Hurst got one all saddled if
you've got the coin how much coin do I
have it's the one with the saddle you
mean there only one there my horse my
horse lady out you better hurry up all
of you run ha ha ha ha I finally have a
horse why a horse of course all right
now I'm heading straight that way really
to appreciate the gigantic scale of this
you know this whole world
it's just really beautiful the things
that were able to do I always loved I
love love love open world persistent
games like this it's phenomenal it's
just a great feeling
you get that feeling of grandeur what
hey it's a dragon
hahaha perfect oh oh get some if you're
not even named hahaha what chance do you
have oh oh yes my horse is fighting oh
what that hit can plus a rejuvenation
potion hahahaha
regeneration potion favorite that honk
oh you come on in
it's gone in you're gonna get something
Oh
doesn't even hurt doesn't even hurt but
there's a wolfed really Lydia you're
having trouble with that wolf there come
on my posters wearing up your face
swords up blood come here come here
buddy oh yeah
get some no I'll give me some special
kill ya funk yah horsey yeah I'm the
best
oh so best so look at your face go up oh
that's a shield for Lydia I'll give that
to Lydia - lady I got some I got a
present for you Lydia thank you
yeah yeah baby carry abba-baba-baba you
get these sankt wait is the orcish no
sexified you get that oh yeah you
welcome apparel you get that oh you're
so welcome
I know I know babe I know you don't have
to I know I know this is only gonna
cause her to throw herself at me some
more but whoa whoa it's a fire it's a
fire thingy oh it's as burns oh okay I
was like wow I was about to attack it
talked to it
I got a dragon soul whoosh yes I am
leading on on my horse
Doody sporran come on gang
keep up where are you oh you so slow all
right now on the way to Sky having
temple how's this guy he said the
location was lost forever but now sudden
he just knows about it magically I mean
if if everyone in the world had
forgotten about this place no matter how
legendary it was then I doubt that he
could just like oh I know that I'll run
you down moose you caribou Oh another
dragon holy hell
they're coming out of the walls Oh blood
dragon eh
Galloway Lydia really Lydia you're gonna
yeah oh that actually does hurt a lot
dress
um storm marking dark wait how do I
I've never even really used astral whoa
I'm about to die
level up perfect timing health and yes
finally two images backup this more
damage roll okay that did oh there it is
now that should be good
come here buddy where you are yeah there
you are come on where's Esbern and
Delphine what are they doing whoa stab
them Pancho yeah attack my storm think
I'm a bobber I guess I could help out
where's my bow Orcas bow
[Music]
come on
Oh what's this epic aiming oh yeah that
was a hit
oh yeah I want to see another hit watch
this epicness uh uh boom all such a
headshot Oh another one all another hit
are you hitting are you attacking dragon
you're attacking a mammoth why oh my god
that's a giant all right okay
you
all right I'm recording again fantastic
we crashed phenomenal because I tried to
save with a worst time in crash oh did
say it did save ah it did
oh yeah what's that dude over there
tryin really they're doing that dragon
is tough I'll tell you that look like
wicked tough oh I think I got a mod that
made the Giants bigger cuz that guy is
like holy hell big
I don't want hit up whoever threw that
marble wall by kaboom yeah headshot Oh
another one
nail them uh-huh archery increase yeah
you saw that was another all right screw
this guy this guy's just like doing
nothing while we're getting up we're
saddling up we're getting out of here
because this guy is doing nothing for us
come on horsey I can't even name you
you're just my horse whatever it don't
matter moving on moving on caribou don't
care we're going to our destination and
nothing nothing you can say can stop us
water water might stop can I have a Ford
water
yeah no problem
oh that blunt dragon is almost dead all
those giants and those mammoths must be
doing them in seems stupid like why
would that dragon go pick a fight with
him
giant well I'm right there no no and it
never landed either so they didn't want
to mess with me
man this place is farther away than I
thought there's another dragon another
one look at that see in the distance
there oh whoa whoa not in combat mounted
archery epicness get some Dargan get
some you ain't got nothing oh this is
awesome actually where my buddy's where
my peeps at oh it's oh he's resurrecting
another dragon that's why I got you can
I save without crashing this time thank
you thank you very much hello buddy
suck some arrows down your throat not
today
not while I'm watching
yeah let's get out of here I can hit you
from there you like it okay what did
that do can I interrupt in did I break
the game
I think I broke the game whatever moving
on forward it don't matter it don't
matter I don't know where my friend is
yeah yeah yeah
I don't find hopefully or else the game
is gonna totally be bored litleo for you
baby
I'll miss you come back to me I'm sorry
for all the times I sliced you with my
giant sword
that's a cougar it's eight a camp an
entire camp and ate it hi it's a blood
dragon no I'm not picking a fight with
you this time you get out of here gold
no cheer I know your words where the
hell are we why am i by myself
girl this screw you all wolves getting
out of here
oh it's another one of those dragon
burial sites okay we've got sort of a
camp going on here
get away blood dragon off shut up horsey
you could take it your tongue okay
what's gonna happen to my horse if
you're gonna be waiting for me I come
out or what
whoa hello excuse me pardon me give me
give me I need to get here excuse me
horsey go in the Cape and the Cape desk
mount horse before going oh you don't
want to mess with me
you don't want to mess with me lady oh
yeah oh yeah you're my horse done
[Music]
or gone that way you don't have any yeah
your avatar I need to sell more crafters
full lawn crap
and hopefully Lydia and there they are
where's Lydia there you are
Oh Lydia you've secured me you scared me
darling I missed you so what for
fighting
sorry alright I got distracted yeah not
enough business though
oh no mercy
you were shocking me the crap out of me
goodness gracious no mercy for you okay
its ingredients not much gold ocean sold
yeah something did my eye again yeah if
the location was lost how are these
people here akka very fantastic oh I see
it's like somewhere else that there's a
puzzle and the symbol for King uh-huh
and work here and of course the symbol
for dragon that's the one that appears
to have a sort of arrows pointing down
okay the symbol on the left what
wait what am I doing here their life in
that sky Haven timber okay there we go
that's not a that's not a locking victim
no one would be kept out by that rarr
let's see what those old blades are
gonna die from oh yeah it's my sword
whoa now Lydia Lydia Lydia watch out let
me activate the friggin Jade do not kill
me I see it I see chain activate come on
as burn s burn hello no actually I'm
actually all out of time thank you guys
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next part
bye bye